makes them feel ugly and unworthy
there's too many reasons you guys okay
how many guys
you guys are all you're pretty girls you
have your pick of the litter
like you
stop stop i'm saying like you have your
pick of the litter you guys that 21 22
could pick a nice guy that you could get
married to
and so it's it's on you if you're 50 if
you're 30 single and childless you're
bad at picking men it's like that's on
you
why would they have to be always on the
woman because it is because this is the
thing like like why why can't we just
take accountability for our decisions
because it takes two to tango it's kind
of just
now you say it takes two to tango but
let's keep it 100.
who's the person that's opening their
legs is it the guy or is it the girl so
okay let me tell you something my friend
i get into a relationship with you right
we get honest beautiful you do you
listen to me you make me feel loved and
then one day you grow into something
because at the end of the day people
grow and they change constantly change
is constant for sure and two years down
the line you actually feel different
because it's just life okay you met
somebody that you connect with more and
you don't want to be with me anymore and
you leave me i've tried my best and i
wanted to be with you but actually i'm
not your soul mate you found your soul
mate and you left me
okay you're saying how is that my fault
you're saying it makes you feel love
whatever [ __ ] but let's keep it real
you girls like the bad boys and these
boys don't even make you feel like they
give you minimum attention not everyone
but modern females strictly do and they
do not typically either yes they do
because if they do they wouldn't that
around their 19 to 25 they would like
give more attention to the nice guys you
guys don't think that there's a group of
women that that enjoy chasing after the
futures and the drakes of the world okay
that's the best thing you said there's a
group of women it's not women in general
when we say modern women that is who
we're talking about
the sierras
correct definition of a modern woman or
is that just what we're going with today
because i wouldn't say that's the
correct resolution or if that's how
you're so what's your definition of a
modern woman
i think somebody you know how you get
the whole beyonce independent woman i
don't basically i think everything that
you would put in the category of a
modern woman but not just looking for
the bad boy not just this i think with
more depth to her do you know what do
you mean more depth i think the modern
woman do you know who's a good example
for modern woman now i think rihanna is
a good example somebody that hustled and
found her love and she settled down on
that love and her and her man are doing
projects together they're working
together and now they have a baby and
they look happy
she's richer than him let me tell you
something though he's a bad boy he has
the clout he has the status and he's the
10 percent ally
okay but that's because she's the one
percent would you like
but so you you used rihanna right but
for every girl that tries to be rihanna
and tries to lock down that guy there's
a million that don't and so there's a
million unsuccessful rihanna's i guess
and so she she's in the top what ten
percent of beauty in her prime you know
she's over 30 now so let's drop her down
a point but like like in general to
rihanna's level asap rocky is here
actually and that's what i do they say
that again because rihanna is the
superstar rihanna is but men don't care
about that i know but i'm just saying an
example of a beautiful powerful rich
woman who actually went for somebody
that she fell in love with and for her
he's the right guy whether he's rich or
not
oh yeah the bad boy
but again she doesn't really have it
doesn't mean he's a bad boy you don't
know what they want
she's lucky she's that beautiful because
outside of that she doesn't generally
have what men want purity and youth she
was known for giving like like there was
some national headline of her giving
some dude an std
okay
so and and so she's not pure and then
she's old she's she's like 32 or
something okay men are measured on
success and women are measured on age
fact yeah yeah so and so that's an
appearance it's not wow it's not it's
not fun i'm not i don't like it's not
fun that's why linda's winning right but
can i just say something at the end of
the day now we can judge and say all of
this stuff but then now at the end of
the day is
if
she's got kids with this guy
they probably will get married if they
haven't already got married in secret
they can actually live happily ever
after because what it and i don't know
what the ins and outs of their
relationships are but judging for more i
can see and given the past that she's
had in the the man that she has found
he's somebody that respects her clearly
somebody that they that she trusts and
he trusts because they're collaborating
a lot of rocky
that was rumors and so all i'm trying to
say is that do you really think asap
rocky is faithful like did you know that
you never know you never know not every
single rapper listen listen a bad boy is
that rocky isn't faithful she's probably
still gonna be even because she's the
type of men if you look at her past
dating issue chris brown drake all these
men what are they all having that in
common they're all sleeping different
type
fully and having a baby with him it's
because he might be
he's the one for her she's the one
the modern women you gave an example of
is like still doing the same [ __ ] no
like even the example you guys gave like
that's a perfect example i don't know
like i would describe myself as a modern
woman but i don't think i'm the kind of
modern woman no see what she's talking
about is a modern woman that acts as
substance
let's keep her 100 the modern woman that
don't have substance believe they're
like the top prizes are like rihanna and
they feel entitled to certain behaviors
let me tell you something so let me tell
you something like
a staple of the modern woman right
they believe
that they are higher than their level
right so i've always said
you see when you take your makeup off
and your lashes off and your nails off
and your wig off and your hair inches
out
and then you go to bed that's what you
are that's your level don't count
oh i love that i i feel like i always
get this though yeah hang on hang on
hang on hang on
don't act like you're higher than your
level because you put makeup on and
weave
level no my dear because the bottom line
is when a man goes to bed with you
you've gone back down to that level and
that is what he's seeing on a daily
basis when you're walking around the
house that's what he's seeing so don't
act
like you're a 10 when you're a uh
and at carnival and at carnival when i
was asking i went around i said rate
yourself one to ten
ten of them ten i'm a ten i'm a ten i'm
a ten bro you're like a five you're an
average loser yeah and i said it's
almost [ __ ] is it not okay to set to
be confident though no no no but it's
not okay to light your it's not okay to
lie to yourself but let's keep it 100
you see the make up the wick it's all
it's all a mask it's a mask i personally
believe that when girls are have makeup
when you approach them they have a
different personalities if you're
approaching
when you approach them without makeup
they tend to be more approachable more
talkable
more have more of a vibe but when you
approach them when they have makeup
they're all like i'm the [ __ ] i'm
their homework do you know what i'm
saying they're longer and they will look
totally different
fishing
videos i can't do makeup
ladies we've all seen the tick tock
videos of women looking a certain way
doing her makeup and looking at the
whole crowd
right okay so there are a lot of women
out there me
brandon
uh what's your name again bro fury out
we don't need to do that we are
beautiful we look like this right but we
will look like this all the time wait
yourself do you look like now i'm just
saying the truth because a lot of women
like don't think they tell me because of
all these makeup all these fake things
but us men
as many of you know i was just banned on
tic tac and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible